this program contains copyrighted
material that may be used for purposes
such as criticism comment news reporting
teaching scholarship or research under
the provisions of section 107 of the
Copyright Act of
1976 All rights to the copyrighted
material used in this program are
reserved to their respective
[Music]
owners
meet a young man who was drawn into
hermetica and gnosticism through heavy
metal music despite having been
Enchanted and seduced by the realm of
black and white white magic he overcame
finding Christ and dedicating his life
to serving him we welcome Davey John
Garcia as he continues to share his
experience with the religion of heavy
metal music welcome back thank you for
having me so let's start uh by exploring
what happened in the last episode catch
our audience up sure we we went through
the the story of my upbringing and how
the there was a lot of occult influence
in my in my family life and my early
life and there's a lot of dark
Supernatural events in my household that
fostered this fascination with the
occult and paranormal and which later
led into dark Heavy Music which
Amplified all these things and how I got
very heavily involved in dark Heavy
Music and the Occult until finally I was
freed from that and I found Christ amen
well let's go into what you mean by a
dark spiritual environment in the
home okay okay
so back when I was very young I me and
my parents would experience a lot of
strange apparitions in the home um we
thought maybe that they were ghosts that
we lived in a haunted house we weren't
really sure what they were but we would
see strange things that weren't there
and we would hear bumps in the night and
hear uh or feel something touch us pull
our hair push us down the stairs
um and just the feeling of always being
watched especially at night and this was
a this was a constant in in the home
growing up so you were able to find out
that Not only was your grandmother and
your mother practicing witchcraft but
that your father was or grandfather was
a part of a secret society known as the
the Freemasons yes okay so there's this
backdrop of just heavy dark spiritual
influences yes and then it opens up this
curiosity
and this kind of a interaction trying to
understand that realm more yes yes very
much so so then you find heavy metal
music let's go into that dive into what
happened and what secrets you were able
to get from there well I got I got very
involved in in this type of music
because at the time I was becoming more
morose depressive and I developed a
deeper attraction to Darkness and this
was perfect for um this was perfect BEC
for getting into the dark heavy music
because it I felt like that music
understood who I was and it really
resonated with what I was feeling and
what I was going through and it helped
me to feel less alone and feel connected
with a a greater community of other
people who also kind of understood what
I was going through so it gave you
identity yes very much so and at that
time it was kind of like any other Vice
to where when you start off it has to
increasingly get more and more intense
in in order to get the same feeling that
you got from the beginning so as I got
into the music it wasn't overtly Ault
but the more I got into it I I needed it
to be darker and heavier and more
intense and more more Blasphemous and
extreme so there's a kind of a thirst
and a lust that it's it's feeding into
absolutely absolutely and so what
messaging did you find and actually what
kind of music I mean we we're saying
heavy metal but who are some of the
bands that you were listening to so
whenever I got into it the most
intensely the it's a subg genre of metal
called black metal and black metal it's
it's the most Blasphemous occult music
maybe that exists it's so is that like
Marilyn Manson or oh it's or is he like
baby steps compared to this stuff yeah
honest honestly yes a black metal it's
um it's all the vocals are like
shrieking whales it's like sounds scary
shrieking whales very intense drums like
the faster and more intense the drums
like it's almost like a a a point of
Pride with how intense you like the the
you're trying to convey the sound of
like a storm or just raw chaotic
violence through the drums and the the
guitars are just you know layered cars
on top of each other that sound like you
know like chainsaws just it's just this
chaotic cacophony of sound that's meant
to overwhelm you and and evoke you know
dark violent spiritual forces and the
lyrics are outwardly Blasphemous it's
anti-christian they love they Revel in
upside down crosses inverted pentagrams
the whole pageantry of Satanism it's a
fullon Embrace as as much as you can
imagine so was there a look as well that
went along with this the music and the
attitude sure sure the the performers
they usually wear if cuz uh if you're in
the audience you might be familiar with
a band like Kiss You know from the 70s
it's it's similar to that it's like
black and white face paint yeah it's
black and white face paint and usually
you know everyone has long hair you know
that's just a part of the aesthetic the
long hair black and white face paint lot
of leather leather jackets um spikes you
know uh chains a lot of a lot of uh
black leather and that's kind of the
whole aesthetic of it and so I've also
noticed that there's kind of like an AFF
feminite look to everything as well what
is that um about do you know you know in
uh in black metal it's black metal it's
less it's less eff feminite it's it's
actually fairly it's fairly masculine in
the sense of it's very aggressive it's
extremely aggressive and
assertive and it's uh I I would say it's
less AFF feminite than maybe some of the
some of the more mainstream variants
like Marilyn Manson like Marilyn Manson
is like very a feminine kind of glories
in the genderbending aspect of it this
one wasn't so much that it was more it
was very strongly masculine but you will
find the gender you masculine or just
kind of demonic and oppressive sh I I
would yeah I would say that the it would
be a kind of the masculine expression of
demonic forces anger right right so
there's this cacophony raining down on
you and emotionally what is this doing
to you well when you're listening to
it because for me I was I was already
becoming possessed by these forces and
it was it was channeling this kind of
nihilistic rage that I had for the world
you know I I I hated everything I hated
people I started hating my parents Inc
hated Society like I hated everything
except music and this was it felt like
it was channeling these forces and at
the time it feels good because it feels
like you're getting all this rage out of
you but you're not really getting it out
it's just you're churning it you're
building it right it's kind of cycling
through you and the more you listen to
it really over time in your life the
angrier the more depressed and morose
that that you become but while you're
listening to it it's like it feels like
a
cathartic spiritual
so is there a message in these almost
chant likee you know
lyrics yes it's a the the message is
it's a full rejection of life itself wow
it's a it's a full rejection of society
and religion and God and um really
really life itself it's a it's a worship
of death okay it's a worship of of death
and everything that's destructive and
violent and ugly and distorted and
chaotic and it's it's a it's a worship
and a a love of those things and a full
rejection of anything that's that's um
speaks of religion or beauty or order or
anything associated with mainstream
Society so it sounds like a religion of
hate would you say that's sure sure and
so did it actually lead you into the in
the direction of a particular spiritual
you know
denomination well I think that's how it
uh that's how that's how it pulled me in
because I I had those feelings inside of
me and so I felt that this really
resonated with me but as I as I got
deeper into it I I started to develop an
attraction to other bands that had that
same chaotic angry veneer but it also
started hinting at deeper
spiritual understandings mhm and
esotericism and and things of this
nature that you know there's that there
actually is a truth out there but
religion is lying to you religion is
lying especially Christianity
Christianity is the main tool of
Oppression that's used to trick people
into believing in into a false god but
there is a real God out there there is a
real something that we come from a real
truth according to heavy metal right but
this isn't it this is this is lying to
you
interesting well we know that studies
show scientifically speaking that music
has the ability to bypass the frontal
lobe so it skips all reasoning and it
goes into a deeper level um so how did
you find yourself seeking that secret
knowledge well at the time because it's
it's hand in glove where I got involved
in the occult around the same time I got
into the music and so the
the practices that I developed in the
oul I would I was into divination like
Spirit boards and Tarot cards and things
like this and as I got into that I
started reading a lot of the literature
that was associated with it and me and
my friend we were in a we're in a a
black metal band at the time his name is
Paul we're in a black metal band at the
time and we were we would always engage
in these oul practices together we were
both into this the same music the same
oul practices we we grew up in a very
similar way and whenever we would be
interacting with these Spirit boards and
these divination tools that's actually
when we got the idea to start a band to
begin with and the we were using a a
Ouija board and when we're communicating
with with with this being this entity it
actually gave us the idea to start a
band and that's that's the whole way we
we got into it and it would even
recommend things to do to to to
strengthen this connection that we had
and that's when I started looking into
hermetica and gnosticism and it it kind
of gave me like glimpses of what to do
but whenever I would do these practices
it was never super overt because as I
got into these practices it's not like a
it's not a full
intellectual knowledge that you're
trying to gain it's more revelatory okay
it's like a re
experience because as you get deeper
into this your the idea of of
hermeticism and no these two practices
you're you're ultimately trying to
you're trying to become like a god
really there's there's this idea that
there's this secret knowledge that's
been withheld from you right but was
given to these great maybe you could
call them prophets great teachers a long
time ago people even like people like
Moses or like Jesus or like Buddha some
of these great teachers in the past
these things were revealed to them by
the true God but over time had become
obscured and that religion was was
created by these people but really these
are just superficial understandings of
the truth of a larger right and really
there's a true theology that's hidden
underneath and all of these different
religions are pointing to the same true
Theology and I started reading books
like the uh the Corpus
hermeticum um the The Emerald
Tablets uh the did you get into Alistar
Corley at all yes yes he's he's very
much a part of the the Hermetic aspect
of it he was involved with with Cults
like the Golden Dawn and that's actually
where the popularity of tarot cards come
from is from Alistar Crowley and the
Golden Dawn but yes he has his own
practice called thma which is just
another faction of the the Hermetic
movement which the ultimate goal is to
become like a god so you're really deep
now in hermetica gnosticism you know the
the teachings of Alistair Crowley you're
depressed you're you're hating the world
why did you continue if if this was the
sentiment that you
had well thing in in one sense things
were actually starting to actually go
quite well for me for the first time
since I can imagine I can remember
rather I started to gain success in my
band we started to make money and gain
you know popularity I wouldn't call it
Fame we weren't famous but where we were
we were we were pretty well known and
you know being on stage and having you
know so many people screaming and giving
you so much energy and attention it's
very it's very seductive and
intoxicating and I felt that my career
was starting to take off and I thought
well maybe music is something I can
actually pursue
fulltime and the more that I got into
these oul practices
it's it's it's like it wanted me to
continue making that music and that it
seemed like there was something there
was something great meant for my life
and the music was wasn't even the whole
thing that was just the beginning
because really the the whole the end
goal of of these practices is to is
really to become like a God and to
escape from this evil false creation
which is the way they view the world
because I I did have this hatred and
this anger but these practices kind of
justify that and say well the reason why
you hate these things is because God the
there's an there's a true God like a but
not like a not like a person the true
God isn't like a person it's more like a
a force like a it's like an emanation of
life really so in yoga in Hinduism they
call it you know the universal God the
the life force energy right it's some
it's something like that but the creator
of this world is not that God it's
actually a a being that they refer to as
the demiurge and uh he has a name name
is yabo and they they talk about this in
some of the apocryphal apocryphal uh
texts like in the Gospel of Thomas and
things like this but which is not part
of the Canon of the Bible right right
right this these are considered Gnostic
or apocryphal texts and they they talk
about the this being but this being is a
is a flawed creation himself it's a
Godlike Transcendent being but it's not
a perfect being okay and that being is
what created this world and this world
is something like a a prison so why
would you submit to a God who is okay
with your suffering who created you know
flaw defected people and wants them to
ultimately become a God and then kill
themselves I I don't what what's the
payoff there for you right well the the
creator of this world is is likened more
to a demon and you're you're what you're
trying to do in these these these
ancient mystery religions like
gnosticism hermeticism you're trying to
gain what they would call a true Soul so
you're not born with the soul a soul is
something you have to obtain and the way
you obtain a soul is by becoming fully
self-actualized n would call The Uber
mench you know you're you're becoming
the fullest expression of yourself and
because it's kind of the idea that you
have this this Divine Destiny there's
you're you're born with glimpses of you
but it's broken and as you Mo move on
through life you're trying to gain the
fullest expression of yourself Carl
Young use has a quote that I'd rather be
whole than good which I think is is
actually a pretty good way of explaining
the Gnostic view of things view right so
they would say that someone like an evil
person right someone like Ted Bundy is
has much more closer to developing a
soul than a random person because it's
all about be the fullest expression of
whatever it is you're giv if you're a
Ser serial killer be the best serial
killer you can be if you're a politician
be the best polit whatever it is it's a
fullest expression of that right that's
a common phrase that I as a yoga
instructor would have to you know coax
people and and motivate them in class
was when they were hitting a pose
whether it was uh warrior pose or bird
of paradise we would say you know
Breathe It In Breathe It Out Hold this
position you know become the fullest
expression of that and and it's just
interesting to me that there's so many
parallels between these divisive forms
of religion and belief um that just
really exalt self yes did you feel
actually exalted
though yes I I felt that by having
access to these beings that would talk
to me okay so not in and of yourself
though did you feel freedom or did you
feel chained to these beings and having
to almost uh live through
them you know in in hindsight yes at the
time I wouldn't have looked at it that
way okay at the time I would have looked
at it that I had the privilege of
divining wisdom from these ascent beings
that are trying to guide me to the end
goal of escaping from this false world
of uh of a false creation cuz you know
this world is it's like a prison it's
like a in hermetica like the world is
almost like a hallucination none of this
is real like you're not real none of
this is real this is all just vibration
it's it's it's all frequency and
vibration and tricks of light that make
things feel like they're physical make
things feel like they're real
but really that's it's not it's none of
this is real and the ultimate goal is to
escape from that and to find the
ultimate nosis which is the ultimate
secret knowledge that's revealed to you
from on high that allows you to gain a
true soul and escape from this and
reunite with God and become God really
that's the that's really the secret
that's the ultimate secret is that
actually you are God right that's really
the ultimate secret and which is the
biggest lie I mean it reminds me of like
a dog chasing its own tail mhm um you
just keep kind of running in this
circular pattern trying new things
trying new ways of supposed
Enlightenment new methods and you end up
getting darker and darker you know
getting into this abysmal um sequence of
things how did you find your way into
Christianity H
well in the last episode we talked
talked about the Bible we talked about
how you discovered you know the the pros
and the poetry and everything within the
Bible and it started to open you up yes
but was it automatic or did you find
yourself in service in a Christian
way well it was a couple of things that
all kind that kind of came together at
the same time you know now I look at it
as Providence but as I was developing a
secular fascination with the Bible and
this is after I had started to move away
from these more ult practi IES and I was
just kind of in Just neutrally In Search
of what truth actually was and after I
had moved away from these dark practices
and I developed this secular interest in
the Bible and at the time when I was
very fascinated with the Bible and I
started reading it out of a secular purs
intellectual Pursuit really I started to
get really sick and during that time I
got really
sick and I it was it was so bad to where
I was starting to question whether I was
going to make it or not I would I would
get these horrible you know I'd wake up
in the middle of the night with this
crushing chest pressure and pain I
couldn't breathe and I had no idea what
was happening to me doctors didn't know
what was happening to me they thought
maybe it was lupus or an autoimmune
disease but no one was sure it was
happening to me wow and just at that
time I happened to run into some seventh
day Adventists who just so happened to
own a Lifestyle Center and just so
happen to specialize in treating
autoimmune disease okay and so at the
same time I'm learning about the Bible I
meet these people and they they barely
knew anything about me but they were
just needlessly loving and kind to me m
and it kind of reminded me of that last
line from that poem from The Book of
John where the the light shineth in
darkness and the Darkness comprehended
it not cuz it I couldn't even understand
why they were being nice to me like why
thinking what do you really want what
are you after right right cuz I had
always viewed Christians as you know
charlatans and uh uh Hypocrites
Hypocrites right Hypocrites and so when
I saw these people who were really
trying to embody the character of Christ
it was very surprising to me and I
couldn't even understand why they would
why they would care about me they barely
knew who I was but they gave me a whole
they showed me the health message right
the Adventist Health message and through
that when I cuz I rejected it for a
while I was stubborn but once I
submitted to it in about 3 weeks I got
better amen and about three weeks I got
better and at that time I remember
thinking about this like you know the
Bible and these people that had come
into my life and I just felt really
grateful right I felt really grateful
and for the first time since I was a kid
I just prayed I just prayed and I I
thanked God whoever you are you know
whoever you are you know if if you're
there if you're real you know thank you
for for helping me and that's that's
really what planted the first seeds in
me that developed into the Christian
walk that I'm on now so you recently
graduated from AFCO tell us a little bit
bit about that yes it was uh that was a
huge blessing and AFCO I wasn't I never
imagined that would have even gotten
into AFCO I I barely even knew what AFCO
was honestly because I've I've been tell
our audience what that is so AFCO it's
the amazing facts uh Center for
evangelism and so um a lot of Christians
who usually they want to become
theologians or pastors or they just want
to deepen their own understanding of
scripture and be able to better share
that with people that are in their
vicinity you go there and they they
teach you how to do that they teach you
more about the Bible they teach you how
to share your faith how to defend your
faith they go deeper into the doctrinal
aspect of it and it's uh it's it's a lot
of work but it's very rewarding it's
very rewarding and is all day it's just
spiritual you know so you get into this
and how long have you been a Christian
at this point about three months that's
incredible just three months yes and you
have to actually be a baptized Christian
for about a year to even get into AFCO
at all it's incredible God just keeps
leading you in the right direction we we
actually want to have that same
experience with some of our members in
the audience would you be so kind to
give them a word of encouragement in
case they have a child who's going
through this or if someone in the
audience themselves is going through
this
yes music music is very powerful it's a
lot more powerful than we give it credit
for and when if you go into any high
school today you'll see that children
will segregate themselves into clicks
based on the type of music that they
listen to you know you'll have the goth
kids and the jocks and different
different types of kids will gravitate
because they form their whole identities
around the music they listen to The
Language they use the the way they speak
the way they think it's all informed by
the music and they get so much they get
so much purpose and meaning from that
and so as a parent don't discount that
you should be be involved in your kids'
lives and don't take lightly of what
they listen to because it could have
profound spiritual ramifications that
could last throughout the entirety of
their life even and so I would encourage
you to be very careful about the music
that you're listening to the music that
you allow your kids to listen to because
it it's it matters it matters a lot and
if you're someone who's currently
involved in something like that don't
forget how how powerful of an effect it
can be having on your psyche on your
your relationship with God because even
music that can seem trivial that's
that's not overtly Blasphemous or
satanic or anything like that can still
be having a very strong effect on your
mind and the way the way you view the
world thank you so much for those words
of encouragement you know when we were
actually developing this program this
series I was researching you know who
and and what to cover because it's
really a broad you know scope and I saw
your AFCO testimony and I really believe
Even This Moment is providential in your
life I can't wait to see where God takes
you
next modern music history seems to
support the idea that Satan has profound
musical ability testimonies of Mega
music stars report of a supernatural
being helping them create irresistible
rhythms Melodies and lyrics in exchange
for promoting things contr contrary to
the Bible these events are truly
prophetic and a sign of the times that
we are currently in we urge you at home
please take time to read your scripture
take time to heed the warnings therein
your salvation depends on it until next
time this has been a wolf's and sheep's
[Music]
clothing